l'invité politique de la matinale ce
matin françois pupponi six députés modem
du val d'oise est avec nous françois
pupponi bonjour merci d'être avec nous
ce matin dans la matinale de rtl avant
que vous entendre je vous propose
d'écouter le président de la république
emmanuel macron qui a donc fixé hier le
cap en ce qui concerne la stratégie
vaccinale on les écoute vous réagissez
dans quelques semaines c'est à dire
début mars nous aurons vacciner
l'ensemble des pensionnaires de maisons
de retraite ce qu'on appelle les ehpad
qui ont souhaité 80% souhaiter ça
représente environ 500 mille de nos
concitoyens ils seront tous vaccinés
début mars on aura vacciner largement au
delà de ces établissements dans cette
période aussi les plus de 75 ans nous
allons continuer cette stratégie et
d'ici à la fin de l'été nous aurons
proposé en france à tous les français
adultes qui le souhaitent un vaccin
alors françois pupponi comment atteindre
cet objectif est ce que ce sera grâce à
l'achat de vaccins russe forcément ce
qui est prévu par le gouvernement depuis
le début c'est de jouer sur les trois
accès qu'aux décodé par l'union
européenne moderna pfizer et astrazeneca
maintenant et donc s'il était prévue
lors qu elle s y ait la possibilité
d'acheter d'autres vaccins qui ont fait
leur preuve pourquoi pas mais dans le
plan vaccinal qui était initialement
prévu ces trois vaccins qui devait
permettre de vacciner tous les français
d'ici l'été
je vous propose d'ailleurs je vous
propose justement de regarder la
réaction de marine le pen à propos du
vaccin russe
maintenant que l'efficacité du vaccin
russe spots nick v ne fait désormais
plus de doute il peut être un renfort
contre la pandémie travaillons en bonne
intelligence avec la russie elles ne le
sont pas l'aider au logis antirusse
ruiner nos capacités à vacciner nos
compatriotes
alors votre réaction à ses propos il
faut distinguer le sanitaire du
politique dans cette crise mondiale et
c'est évident on voit bien d'ailleurs
que les différents laboratoires ont du
mal à livrer les vaccins dans des télés
est reparti ici à d'autres vaccins
qu'ils soient russes ou d'ailleurs voit
le jour qu'il est prouvé qu'il est
effectivement efficace il faudra que
l'union européenne en phase directe
l'acquisition parce que le choix qui a
été fait par la france c'est de
travailler
avec norbert est de faire en sorte de
travailler collectivement et pas chacun
dans son coin
et si effectivement il ya aucune raison
de refuser l'achat d'un vaccin qui
serait plus efficace que ceux où autant
et aussi efficace que je peux nous
utilisons actuellement alors en tout cas
un nouveau conseil de défense
attendu ce matin pour le moment pas de
perspective de confinement le chef de
l'état compte sur la responsabilisation
des français un voyage qui a déclaré
dimanche au jdd le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand
tout laisse à penser qu'une nouvelle
vague pourrait se profiler à cause du
vague pourrait se profiler à cause d'un
nouveau variant mais peut-être
pourra-t-on l'éviter grâce aux mesures
que nous avons décidé tôt et que les
français respectent avec courage et
solidarité avec les plus fragiles alors
comme mesure à la fermeture des
frontières renforcement du louvre feu la
responsabilisation des français qu'on
entend beaucoup beaucoup s'attendaient à
un rebond film en stricte 1re vendredi
ce n'a pas été le choix de l'exécutif
est-ce que ça a été la bonne stratégie
on le verra pour l'instant les chiffres
permettent de penser que les mesures qui
ont été prises jusqu'à présent porté
leurs fruits
li effectivement trop de morts tous les
jours il ya trop de personnes
hospitalisées la situation est tendue
mais elle est beaucoup moins tendue
qu'elle peut l'être au moins de juin et
pour l'instant les choses n'ont pas
l'air de déraper comme certains le
craignaient donc le la fdj ce qu'a dit
faites par le préval public en
particulier le dire puisque pour
l'instant les choses on la veut dire on
est sur le fameux plateau
eh bien faisons le pari que les mesures
qui ont été prises et que le sérieux des
français vont nous permettre de ne pas
être obligé de le recompiler alors
justement sérieux du front des français
le ministre de l'intérieur a avancé une
augmentation des contrôles sains pour
faire respecter les mesures de
couvre-feu et la jauge dans les magasins
va peut-être le voir d'ailleurs sur ces
images les images de contrôle qu'ils ont
fait
le tour voilà on le voit à l'image le
tour des réseaux sociaux justement ces
contrôles massifs dimanche soir sur le
périph sur le périphérique
ça a provoqué pas mal d'incompréhensions
quelle a été votre réaction est ce que
c'est que ces contrôles un voulue par
l'exécutif ils sont indispensables selon
vous dans cette crise sanitaire
bien sûr c'est indispensable parce que
on ne peut pas mettre en oeuvre des
mesures qui change
castrés ctive de liberté de déplacement
pour les français mais qui ont un
objectif c'est de sauver des vies et
qu'il n'ait jamais de contrôle
on le voit aussi à vue relâchement dans
certains endroits on lit les contrôles
dans les restaurants des contrôles dans
les bars des contrôles internes de
magasins et puis c'est vrai que souvent
à 18 heures il ya encore beaucoup de
monde sur les routes et et sur le
périphérique en particulier moi il m'est
arrivé d'y aller pour des raisons
professionnelles et donc effectivement
les contrôles sont indispensables parce
que on ne peut pas mettre des mesures
comme celles là s'il n'y a pas de procès
si l'irak profonde les gens considèrent
qu'on peut quand même quelques pas pour
certains une infime minorité mais
parfois ces nombreux transgresser la
règle
alors il ya aussi la question des écoles
qui inquiète avec un nouveau protocole
qui a été mis en place
plus d'aération de mètres de distance
entre les élèves à la cantine ou encore
la fermeture des classes en cas de co
vide est ce que ces mesures elles sont à
la hauteur des enjeux selon vous oui
parce que pour l'instant on a le
sentiment que les mesures qui sont
prises même quand on les durcir un peu
et il sait l'intérêt parfois des durcir
elles portent leurs fruits la veille
nous sommes dans une situation
les mouches il faut le montrer tout à
l'heure il ya deux fois moins de
personnes en réanimation
aujourd'hui que comme adjoint ou au plus
fort de la crise donc voilà on a le
sentiment que si on peut éviter au
confinement qui c'est dramatique
dramatique pour les personnes
dramatiques pour l'économie si on peut
le faire et bien il faut tout tenter
pour le faire et si aujourd'hui ce qui
est en train de faire le gouvernement y
est je pense qu'ils auraient non à
l'heure après ça nécessite de s'adapter
à chaque fois à des mesures en fonction
de l'évolution de la situation d'arrivée
des variants mais je crois que ces
mesures qui sont successivement prises
ou un intérêt sexualité nal mesure qui
est là la dernière mais je refuse qui
est le confinement total
vous évoquez les conséquences
économiques on a vu
la détresse des restaurateurs on
l'entend ces derniers jours en certains
ont même ouvert le 1er février
comment est ce que vous avez perçu ces
ouvertures
s'il ya des gens qui sont
malheureusement en train de perdre leur
route travaille de pair l'investissement
d'une fille malgré les aides du
gouvernement des aides qui sont
conséquentes mais certains n'y arrivent
pas ils ont tenté le tout pour le tout
pour essayer de sauver ce qui est
parfois l'investissement d'une vie hélas
ce n'est pas bien sûr eu acceptable vis
à vis des règles ont été mises en oeuvre
par le gouvernement mais on peut le
comprendre humainement psychologiquement
donc certains essayent de se remettre au
travail de sauver ce qu ils peuvent donc
c'est il faut bien entendu anconina
éviter il faut les jt en aidant au
maximum ceux qui sont dans la difficulté
je pense que les aides aujourd'hui sont
pour la grande majorité des commerçants
et des entreprises d'autres pays au
niveau de ce qu'il faut faire
moi j'ai participé au débat la forme
nationale mais des choses dans le bon
sens par contre la quiétude sera le jour
où la réouverture où il y aura plus les
aides si l'activité ne reprend pas là
des entreprises seront en très grande
difficulté et la crainte c'est ce qu'il
peut se passer dès la réouverture
et dès la fin des mesures de restriction
là où on pourra malheureusement constaté
une chute conséquente des avec des
entreprises l'activité alors un autre
dossier françois pupponi en ce moment
qu'il suscite le débat c'est la loi sur
le séparatisme et à ce propos jean luc
mélenchon a tenu un discours qui a été
remarquée sur la question mardi à
l'assemblée nationale
on va regarder un extrait puis vous
réagissez toutes les religions sont
d'accord pour dire que votre loi les
menaces en aucun cas la laïcité net un
athéisme d'état
alors jean luc mélenchon qui finalement
a pris fait et cause pour les leaders
des grandes religions en france qui
dénonce le texte
en tout cas elle est défendu la laïcité
est ce qui la raison alors qu'il a
raison de dire que la laïcité ce n'est
pas le refus les religions la laïcité
c'est entre autres la protection et la
liberté est une conscience qui est
assurée d'autres pays donc effectivement
c'est une conception de la visite et qui
n'a pas toujours été la sienne et
aujourd'hui il reconnaît
qu'effectivement la licité c'est aussi
et surtout la protection des vis des
religions et la liberté de conscience
je vais le dire
la vraie question c'est pourquoi au fait
des lois pour lutter pour l'excès de
certains la loi s'applique à tout le
monde ça s'applique à tous les excès et
qu'effectivement moi je participe à
cette cette commission réalisé le texte
les trois grandes religions nice
considère que les règles de contrôle que
nous sommes en train de mettre en place
elle concerne tout le monde y compris
ceux qui depuis les années ne pose pas
de problème c'est une réalité
on leur a aussi expliqué qu on ne peut
pas légiférer seulement pour certains on
légifère pour tout le monde chacun doit
respecter l'arrêt pour éviter des abus
ont peut-être pour conclure je souhaite
également vous entendre sur la question
la proportionnelle à votre chef de file
françois bayrou défend depuis longtemps
à l'instauration de la proportionnelle
pour les élections légistatives et il
faut poser la question aux français par
référendum vous défendez aussi ce choix
oui c'est vrai que c'est une proposition
du tibet en ciel ont d'ailleurs juste
après une réunion entre elles que
proposait la parenté sur ce sujet là et
c'est une c'était aussi une promesse qui
avait été fait de changer le mode de
scrutin et donc il reste pas beaucoup de
temps parce que vous connais la règle
pour changer une loi électorale il faut
le faire plus d'un an avant les
élections
donc on a encore que quelques semaines
pour pouvoir le faire effectivement je
crois qu'un jour ou l'autre il faudra y
arriver parce qu'on voit bien que la
manière dont le scrutin majoritaire
fonctionne prive un certain nombre de
français d'être représentés à
l'assemblée nationale hélas nationale
c'est normal normalement la
représentation du peuple français donc
il faut qu'il y ait une cohérence entre
ce qu'est l'assemblée nationale et le
vote des français
merci beaucoup françois pupponi d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl je le rappelle vous êtes
député modem du val d'oise